as you're coming in we're gonna do a
live experiment so if you go to this URL
it's also on the whiteboard over there
go to the URL you're going to do a one
question survey and then that's going to
take you to the notebook where you'll
see all the analysis for the talk so
let's get started
I'm Allen Downey I teach at Olin College
which is a new engineering school
outside of Austin well 20 years old so
maybe not that new anymore but we're
trying to fix engineering education what
I'm talking about today is the
inspection paradox and I'm gonna explain
using a first example which is suppose I
want to know the average size of
families in the US and I have a
convenience sample which is the audience
at PI data so my first thought is I
could ask you how many children do you
have but a lot of people at the
conference are kind of young your
families are probably not complete at
this point so if I want complete family
sizes all right I've got a good idea
this is going to turn out to be a bad
idea and I'll explain why but here's my
good idea I'm gonna go up a generation
so instead of asking you how many
children you have I'm going to ask how
many children your mother has so that's
what the survey does and again if you go
to that link it'll take you to this
survey and I'm gonna fill that out
here one question is biased
so my mother has three biological
children and now I'm gonna go to this
notebook and hopefully this will allow
me to analyze the results if you haven't
used collab before this is one of a
number of environments where you can
host Jupiter notebooks and their
executable I found it very helpful if
you haven't used notebooks before the
key thing to know is shift-enter
that is how you execute cells and if you
just hit shift enter a few times will
run through the analysis oh no it's not
written by Google that's okay you can
run it anyway so on colab you're in a
virtual environment and you often have
to install things each time you start up
into a book and you can also reach out
to Google sheets which is where the
results went and grab the data looks
like I've got a bunch of Nan's there but
there's probably some good data in there
feet
so that's what the distribution looks
like lots of single children lots of two
family two children families a few
threes a few fours seven is the biggest
number so far
interesting big family I put in a little
check here in case anyone was gonna mess
with me and put in like three hundred so
anything bigger than 20 I'm gonna not
believe you and the mean in this case
turns out to be two and a third okay
interesting so of all the families that
I just surveyed the average size is two
and a third but in the US the average
lifetime fertility is really close to
two at this point so what I'm seeing is
that this group seems to come from a
more fertile family than average and we
could start to ask why and you might
think well it's a it's an affluent group
it's a well-educated group we could
think about race and ethnicity all of
those things might be true and that
might make the average higher or lower
but there's one other really big factor
that's in play here which is if you come
from a family that has no children
you're not here
so families with zero children are not
represented in this room and actually
it's worse than that families with many
children are over-represented it's kind
of like a lottery where the more
children you have the more probability
you have of being in this room and in
general if a family has X children it
will be over-represented in this sample
by a factor of X that's an example of
what's called length biased sampling
where your probability of being in the
sample is proportional to some kind of
size or length or duration in time
usually in a linear way and that leads
to the inspection paradox which is that
if you do subtly different kinds of
sampling you get surprisingly different
results this happens a lot it is not a
super well known thing it's known by
some different names but a lot of people
haven't heard of it once I tell you
about it you are going to start seeing
it everywhere so brace yourself on now
this is often a problem like you can be
wrong or misleading because of this but
it's also an opportunity which is
sometimes you can do clever experimental
design and take advantage of it here's
another example class sizes if you go to
a university or a college and you ask
the teachers how big their classes are
you might get an average like 31 if you
ask students how big their classes are
you might get an average of 56 and you
might think that somebody's got to be
lying but they're both right they're
just reporting averages over a different
population and one of them might be more
descriptive of the teachers experience
and one of them is more descriptive of
the students experience so it's not that
they're wrong they're just measuring
different things you just have to be
careful about what you're measuring and
how you report it so I didn't make up
those numbers this is from Purdue they
published the distribution of class
sizes from a few years ago and you can
see this example there were a hundred
and thirty-eight students who took a
class that had one student in it
must have been an independent study or
something like that but there were 333
classes that were a hundred or more
students so if you're walking around
campus there are only a hundred and
thirty-eight students who will report to
you that they are in a class with one
student but there are 33,000 students
who are going to tell you that they're
in a really big class so you're going to
greatly oversample large classes and
again it will be over over sampled by a
factor of the size itself so I grabbed
their summary statistics and I kind of
filled in the blanks with some random
number generation to get a fake kind of
a fake sample of actual class sizes and
then I used kernel density estimation to
try to get a smooth picture of what that
distribution looks like so very roughly
if you talk to the Dean and they gave
you the actual distribution of class
sizes this is roughly what it would look
like and now this is the technical
content of this talk if you have the
biased if you have the unbiased
distribution you can compute what would
this look like if I asked students by
doing weighted resampling so I'm going
to use numpy random choice to generate a
new sample from the actual sample that I
collected the new sample is going to be
the same size so n is the same size as
the original sample it is sampling with
replacement so some values will appear
more than once other values might not
appear in the resample and it's weighted
in the sense that I'm going to take the
given weights normalize them so that
they add up to one and pass them into
numpy as P this parameter which is the
weights so now if I have the actual
class sizes that's what unbiased is I'm
going to pass in the sample of unbiased
class size and I'm passing in the class
size as the weights so I'm waiting the
distribution using the values themselves
as weights that's the key if you
understand that
understand this entire talk let's see
what that looks like again the blue is
the unbiased view from the point of view
of the Dene that's the actual
distribution of class sizes the orange
is what it looks like for students it
greatly under represents small classes
and greatly over represents large
classes so again this is potentially a
problem if you accidentally measure the
wrong thing but it's an also an
opportunity which is let's say that your
school doesn't publish the distribution
of class sizes and you want to know what
it is you could go around campus and you
could ask students now you know you're
getting the biased view but given the
biased data you can apply the inverse of
that weighting in order to estimate the
actual so here's what I'm doing this is
the sample here is pretending I'm
walking around campus and I interview
500 students and I ask them how big
their classes are and then I'm calling
the same function I called a minute ago
I'm passing the sample as the first
perimeter but now as the second
parameter it's not the values it's the
inverse values because I'm doing the
opposite direction
I'm unbiased so now here's what that
looks like the blue line is ground truth
that's what the actual distribution is
the orange line is the biased sample
that I got when I walked around to ask
students and then I applied the inverse
filter to the orange line and I got the
green line the green line is a pretty
good estimate of the actual distribution
it's particularly good for larger class
sizes it's a little bit less good for
small class sizes because those are hard
to sample there aren't very many people
around to report small classes so I
would need a pretty big sample in order
to estimate that part of the
distribution well but on the whole this
works
so anytime you're not able to get ground
truth data sometimes you can back it out
from a biased sampling process okay
once you become aware of this phenomenon
and you start to see it everywhere so
airline passengers are always
complaining because the flights are
always full airlines are always
complaining because they're flying empty
planes around and losing money who's
lying
possibly neither of them if the flight
is really full there are a lot of people
there suffering if the flight is nearly
empty there are very few people who will
report how much they enjoyed the extra
space how come when you call the call
center
they are always experiencing higher than
normal call volumes because the number
of people who experience that is a lot
same reason you can't get a taxi this is
really interesting article this is from
2012 talking about taxis and there's a
new startup company that we're talking
about that they thought was really gonna
help another example of the same thing
you are waiting for the bus in the rain
and you talk to the public transit
company and they say that the buses run
every twenty minutes on average so if
you arrive at a random time you would
expect to have to wait about ten minutes
on average that's not true in fact you
end up waiting longer because there's
some variability sometimes the buses are
close together sometimes they're farther
apart if there's a big interval between
buses you are more likely to arrive
during a big interval than a small
interval because it's bigger and it's
this it's this linear waiting again your
probability of falling in any interval
is proportional to the length of that
interval
so I got some data this is Kendall
Square on the red line in Boston and the
MBTA publishes live data that I
downloaded for about a week and
collected the time between trains at
Kendall Square during rush hour and
sometimes they end up really close
together like two minutes and sometimes
they're spread out about 16 minutes
apart this is what it looks like if you
are the MBTA that's the Massachusetts
Bay Transit Authority they run the red
line but if you're a passenger and you
arrive at a random interval this is what
you see and I did this the same way by
weighted resampling of the unbiased
distribution I got the orange biased
distribution so it's shifted off to the
right and sure enough the MBTA will
insist that the average is seven point
eight minutes and passengers will insist
that their average is longer and they
are both correct
they are just averaging over different
things now in this case the difference
is not huge because the variance is not
huge as the variance gets bigger the
effect of this biasing gets much bigger
and there's one extreme example of this
so let me ask you a question are you
popular the answer is no and there's
science there's a reason the answer is
no this is actually from Scientific
American so you know this is true this
is the friendship paradox and that is if
I pick you at random and then I pick one
of your friends at random the chances
are about 80% that your friend has more
friends than you do which seems
paradoxical but think about what a
social network looks like so think of it
as a graph each node is a person each
edge or each line is a friendship
between two people this path by the way
I didn't make this I just found this at
random on somebody's blog so first of
all thank you to them but second of all
weirdly so my name is Allen my wife's
name is Lee
I have no idea who liz is if anybody
asks neither do you so one more time if
you think of this as a graph if you
choose a random node and then choose a
random edge and go to its destination
and then for that node you ask how many
friends it has the probability that you
land on a node is proportional to the
number of edges that lead to that node
which is the number of friends so a node
with degree X or number of friends X is
over sampled by a factor of X now in
this case the distribution of friends is
highly variable
so this is going to make a really big
difference this is a data set I grabbed
this is the stanford data sets for for
studying networks they got some data
from a social network company and i
think like 1998 it just had 4,000 users
at the time but they got the number of
friends for each of them and this is
what that distribution looked like so
there are a few people that have
hundreds of friends and lots of people
that just have a small number of
connections in this social network so
this is highly variable and if I now do
the friend sampling process again I'm
going to overweight popular people
there's what the biased distribution
looks like
so people with a small number of friends
are almost invisible in this sampling
process people with hundreds of friends
show up over and over because of the way
I'm sampling and it has a big effect on
the mean in this example the actual
average is about 42 friends per person
but if I do this pick a person and then
sample a friend process the average is
about a hundred so really big difference
once you know about this you start
seeing it everywhere and if you're
running a 200 mile relay race you have a
lot of time to think about this so I ran
this race and I noticed that whenever
somebody overtook me they had just blew
past me there were really fast runners
like Colin and but when I overtook
people I was flying past them and my
first thought is okay maybe this is like
a weird race and it attracts a bimodal
distribution of runners maybe slow
runners and fast runners like relay
races but people in the middle like me
just don't do this format so there's
nobody else out here running at the same
speed as me
by now you have probably figured out
that that is not true because of the way
this format works the runners are spread
out over the course so it's almost a
random sample of different speeds but if
you're out there and running the people
that you see depend on how fast you are
running if you run fast you are likely
to overtake slow people if you run slow
you will be overtaken by a lot of fast
people and in general the probability of
observing another runner is proportional
to the absolute difference between their
speed and yours so this is a little bit
of a variation but it's still this
linear relationship between the size of
the thing that you're measuring and the
your probability of observing it so the
actual distribution of running speeds is
just you know modal but you are applying
a not shaped filter to it which is the
absolute value of the difference between
your speed and theirs and so the result
is a distribution that appears to be
bimodal so let's get some data on this I
didn't get data from the actual relay I
ran but I grabbed a 10k that's a near
where I live and this happens to be my
10k PR I just wanted to put that up
there
it's personal record for people who are
not runners Steve
so here's what the actual distribution
looks like now interestingly it is not a
normal shaped distribution it's not a
bell curve it is skewed out toward fast
people which is kind of interesting by
itself so now I'm gonna take this and
use my biasing process to see what this
would look like if I were running at
seven miles an hour I'm actually faster
than that but at seven miles an hour
what you see is what appears to be a
bimodal distribution now mathematically
it would go to zero it's not doing that
here in part because I'm using KDE and
that's kind of smoothing over the zero
part but that's also probably more
realistic because you know you vary in
speed a little bit you have some chance
of seeing somebody running at your speed
but just a lower chance so that's what
that looks like this happens on the
highway too if you're not a runner you
are likely to see fast people you are
likely to see slow people you are
unlikely to see those same safe drivers
like yourself regardless of what speed
you're going once you see this you start
seeing it everywhere so I read orange is
the new black a while back which is very
different from the television show this
is a memoir of a woman who went to a
federal prison for about 17 months and
one of the things that comes up over and
over in the book is she was very
surprised by the length of the sentences
that her fellow prisoners were serving
now first of all she's right so this is
the incarceration rate in the United
States over the last hundred years and
this is a national disgrace so Piper
Kerman the author of the book is
absolutely correct however she is also
being somewhat misled by the inspection
paradox which is if you arrive at a
prison at a random time and you pick a
random prisoner you will over sample
prisoners in proportion to the lengths
of their sentences
the longer they're there the more likely
you are to observe them so we can get
data on this this is from the Bureau of
Prisons they actually update this
monthly so you can get distribution of
imposed sentences for the current
population in prison so this is a case
where the data that they are publishing
is already length biased because it is
based on a snapshot of the current
prison population so they are over
sampling long term prisoners and under
sampling short timers however we can
take the biased data and apply the
inverse filter like this now in this
case federal prisoners typically serve
about 85% of their nominal sentence and
at the federal level there's actually
not very much variation on that by and
large you get a sentence you serve 85%
of it so we can use eighty-five percent
of the nominal to figure out the actual
time and then apply this inverse filter
one more time so there's what it looks
like now the orange line is the original
data that I collected from the Bureau of
Prisons the blue line is the inferred
actual distribution of sentences and as
you can see there are actually many more
short timers the most common sentence is
actually a year in a day but they're not
in prison very long and so they don't
show up in the data very much now here's
where this gets interesting we figured
out if you're like a judge and you see
every sentence go by you get an unbiased
view if you visit a prison once and you
take an instantaneous sample you get the
purely biased view but what do you see
if you're there for an interval of time
like 13 months you're going to see
something in between those two views
and in particular it works out that if
you inspect if your inspection processes
for a duration T and there's a prisoner
with a sentence length X your
probability of sampling them is
proportional to X plus T so that when
that's small that converges to the
completely biased view and as it goes to
infinity it converges to the completely
unbiased view but we can compute in
between what it looks like which is to
take X which is the same 85% of your
nominal sentence and T which is the
amount of time that you're in prison
so 13 months converted into years and so
the weight is X plus T so I now take my
unbiased view apply these weights and I
get the Greenline so just one more time
the blue is the unbiased orange is what
you would see if you just arrived with
an instantaneous snapshot and the green
is what you would see if you were there
for 13 months now interestingly it's not
very different from the instantaneous
view you actually have to be there for a
very long time before you start to
converge on the blue line this also
happens in multiple dimensions but even
more so so in two dimensions you get a
linear weighting in three dimensions you
get a quadratic weighting and as you go
up to n dimensions you get a weighting
of X to the power of n minus 1 which
gets really big and this is the basis of
a claim that you might have heard which
is that if you have a multi-dimensional
distribution all of the probability mass
falls in a thin shell that is not at the
origin it's not at the mean now this I'm
not going to explain too much of this
today this is what that looks like in
two dimensions if the unbiased
distribution is a pure Gaussian so
that's just half of a normal
distribution there
the biased distribution is the orange
line and as you can see the most likely
value is not at the center at zero the
most likely value is away from the
origin if you're curious about that I
decided to kind of skip over that today
but you can look in my blog I have an
article there where I wrote about that
this is the dartboard paradox and the
note book that I sent you two also has
the details in it so to summarize again
this kind of length biased sampling pops
up in a lot of domains and has different
names in different domains but my
impression is that it's not super well
known but once you become aware of it
you start to see it everywhere and you
can think of it as a chance to do some
clever experimental design before I let
you go let me just point out if you want
to read more about some of these
examples the class size is in think
stats which is available as a free
download and the redline example is in
think Bayes if you have friends who are
a little bit less technical they might
like this version which is written for a
kind of a more popular audience
explanation of this now I published this
article and nobody asked about the
picture so why is that the picture for
this article it's a paradox
couple of quick publisher public service
announcements the PI data group in
Boston has been kind of quiet for a
little while but is ramping up again so
if you live in Boston or you're visiting
help us get this going when there are a
few thousand members already and
hopefully some events coming up soon you
can also help me figure out what to do
during my sabbatical next year I have an
an article here that explains what I am
capable of doing and your job is to tell
me which of those things I should do so
so help help me out there and if you
would like to get in touch with me there
are five different ways that you can do
that so questions thoughts what do you
think
and obviously this is should be useful
to think of an experimental design do
you have any tips on things to the
patrolling should I be looking for
things where I'm looking at time or
looking at distance good question let me
let me repeat it so your observation is
that some of these examples were obvious
some of them it would take a minute and
then it would click and others you're
kind of like oh I might have made that
mistake I'm paraphrasing and so you're
asking so is there like a checklist that
you can go through which is if you're
measuring things that are in time or
space should the light bulb go on - oh I
better watch out for her length biased
sampling I might put it on my to-do list
or my checklist along with all the other
kinds of sampling bias so you know I
gave the examples earlier of you know
you'd pick a group of people they're not
necessarily representative of the US
population if that's what you're trying
to measure so I guess it's on my list of
think about sampling bias and maybe just
add inspection bias as one of the
checklists other thoughts or questions
yeah
we often talk about the survivorship -
yeah it's kind of like your people with
no children don't answer the question in
this room yes and I'm wondering if
that's just one end of a spectrum and
you're just you just described it in
spectral force great question again let
me paraphrase it so you're saying that
this is reminding you of Survivor bias
that very often when you try to sample a
population there will be people who
aren't in that sample exactly because of
the property that you're trying to
measure now in the case of survivorship
it's kind of binary they are either
there or not depending on whether they
survive or not and in this case it's a
continuous degree of over sampling but
yes there's a connection there and maybe
add that to the checklist survivor bias
yeah
do I have an opinion about how to
interpret the Doomsday argument
what is the Doomsday argument
it's given an estimate of the total
number of humans born so far simply put
it says that supposing that all humans
are born in a random order chances are
that anyone who
so if assuming if you think of everyone
who has ever been born or will ever be
born on average you should expect to be
in the middle and if it's like an
exponential growth then you should
expect to be very close to the end is
that what you're getting it right so
depending on how you interpret you'll
come to a different conclusion now I'm
wondering how much the exponential
growth assumption is built into that
because if that's not true if we get to
a steady state or even start to roll
over then I think it's not the case
anymore that we should assume that we're
near the end and in fact on global
population it looks like that's where
we're headed it looks like we're going
to peak around 2100 and then global
population will start to decline so I
don't know I'm just making stuff up
other thoughts or questions all right
thank you very much
[Applause]